foreign
[Music]
coming up on FYI
should we be worried about artificial
intelligence
I think it's okay to use AI as long as
there's lots of rules and regulations
put into place as it could get real out
of hand if we getting
[Music]
and this dog has just won a world record
but can you guess what for
[Music]
hello this is FYI your Weekly News show
where we bring you all the latest on all
the top stories and this week we're
going to start off with something that's
been in the news a lot recently
artificial intelligence AI is technology
that enables a computer to think or act
in a more human way it does this by
taking in information from its
surroundings and deciding its response
based on what it learns or senses in
theory AI could make a lot of things
easier from everyday tasks like writing
emails to medical procedures
however some of ai's inventors and other
experts have come forward with concerns
about how powerful AI can become in the
future
we don't understand how these systems
work we don't know what they're capable
of and that means that we can't control
them we can't get them to behave
themselves yeah and I also seen that the
UK prime minister Rishi sunak had a
meeting with the U.S President Joe Biden
over possible threats from AI yeah I
mean I think it's good that they're
taking caution but it is quite scary I
find it so scary and other people are
concerned that young people like us
could use AI to cheat on things like our
homework with online services like
Chachi PT being able to write realistic
School essays in seconds yeah I can see
how that would be tempting other people
are worried about AI replacing people in
workplaces such as call centers which
would mean loads of people losing their
jobs well we wanted to get your shout on
this so we headed to Norwich Primary
School in Glasgow to hear what the
pupils thought about AI thank you
AI is a good thing to help us with
dangerous situations like yeah going to
space going to Mars but also going in
volcanoes and exploring like the bottom
of the sea and it could take over jobs
that people really don't like it can
help scientists with research for
vaccines and cures to different diseases
I want AI to do I don't like doing it's
probably cleaning my room or like
folding clothes or putting with the
dishes or something should we be afraid
of the eye some things yes but other
things no I think it's okay to use AI as
long as there's lots of rules and
regulations put into place as it could
get real out of hand if we didn't I
don't think it should be stopped I think
it should be stored in like a lot you
can get worried about it like because
people are saying that yeah I could
possibly potentially take over the world
but some people aren't afraid of that
because they really don't believe it in
my opinion I don't think anything's that
bad about AI either do you think the AI
should be allowed to help with homework
from Masters pet stuff
um yeah well if your mum and dad work
all the time and you do it in your mum
Dad don't have time to help with you but
it's also be good I think it's like help
you work out how to get to the answer if
they can explain it to you
yeah I agree with that it should be able
to help you but not just do it for you I
don't think the AI should be helping
with homework because it basically
counts as cheating and if you're a
teacher found out then you'd probably
get like very bad grades
[Music]
so we all know that football is great
for keeping us active and having fun but
how much can it also help our mental
health well Jiraiya went to meet Premier
League footballer Tim ream to find out
more
[Music]
[Applause]
is not only film's Captain he is also an
international player and paid for the US
in the last World Cup
the reason I'm here is to hear more
about his work as an ambassador for an
organization called virtual soccer
school or VFS that is having a worldwide
effect on young people's mental health
and
[Applause]
sorry sorry
that was a bit much
well done
so can you tell me a little bit about
virtual Circle school and why it's
important yeah so virtual soccer schools
we travel around the world virtually and
and we speak to kids about mental health
um about what it means and how it
relates to Everyday Life how it relates
to football we kick it off with
questions it comes from founder Tom lamb
and then we open the floor and let
students come to the screen and interact
and we talk about anxiety we talk about
pressure we talk about
nervousness we talk about just
everything because I've learned through
my football career that my mental health
and I'm not in a good place than
physically I'm going to feel sluggish
I'm not going to feel great and I
learned that what's important to talk
about it as a
I think one of the biggest is always a
change in situation or a change in
manager and new ideas come with with a
new manager those challenges are
difficult and you sometimes think am I
good enough can I do this you know not
knowing what they are going to think of
you is a big challenge everybody thinks
as a footballer that everything is just
so perfect all the time you know that's
that's never been the case anybody who
tells you it is is not telling you the
truth so what would you say to someone
who's struggling with their Mental
Health
um speak to somebody they're checking in
on each other checking in on on your
friends checking in on family members is
is probably the easiest quickest way to
look after yourself and look after
others I'm not moving promise
it's a bad pen sorry though you hit it
with Pace oh my goodness
[Music]
so one of the biggest stories in the
news this week is Prince Harry's
appearance in court so what's going on
well we've been investigating
yeah it's part of a legal case against
mirror group newspapers who owns some
really well-known newspapers like the
Daily Mirror the Express and the Sunday
people Prince Harry is suing them
because he believes that they've only
gathered private information by using
illegal methods such as hacking his
phone phone hacking is when someone
secretly uses Force to gain access over
recorded voicemail messages Harry claims
mirror group newspapers then published
his private information in their papers
against his will the newspaper group
denies all allegations
and he's not the only celeb taking
action a hundred other people including
expert bowler Ian Wright and pop star
Cheryl Cole are also seeing the mirror
group for phone hacking so why is it
such a big deal that Prince Harry is
giving evidence
well it's not the typical Royal thing to
do Prince Harry will actually be the
first senior Royal to give evidence in a
trial in over 130 years the last time
was back in 1891 when Edward VII gave
evidence in a dispute over a game of
cards
well there's another thing I saw in the
news recently Prime the famous energy
drink so Maya have you tried it yet I
have actually tried it I didn't really
like it it was very sweet I thought it
was alright to be honest with you I
think it's really only popular because
it's just another craze you know yeah
and I know a lot of people are drinking
it within schools but maybe not for much
longer as some schools are now Banning
the drink as they feel it's too much of
a distraction for pupils Prime is an
energy and hydration drink created by
social media celebs KSI and Logan Paul
when it was first released in 2022
people scrambled to get a bottle with
shop selling out or rushing in it to one
per customer so it may be popular but
some teachers aren't so sure one school
said they were Banning it as having a
bottle became a major distraction in
lessons
have you got a toy car collection well
check this out six-year-old Daniel and
his dad Ross love toy cars so much that
they started posting photos of Daniel's
collection in different places around
the country from Edinburgh Castle to
Buckingham Palace
they're now celebrating 1 000 days of
Staffing cars at different UK landmarks
and have had messages of support from
all over the world nice one guys
[Music]
well I know this month for a lot of us
is all about exams and I know it can be
a little bit of a struggle sometimes
yeah it can be a pretty stressful time
exams definitely aren't for everyone and
what happens if you don't get the result
that you want
well if you just don't get it then don't
worry because javai has been getting
some top tips
racing hot
sweaty hands
[Music]
not sleeping too well with revision bits
piling up high it's easy to get worried
about exams crashing towards you
[Music]
well I
have tips to help you out and before you
go through all your books out the window
and hiding under your bed remember
everyone's going through the same thing
so you're not alone and it's natural to
be a bit stressed it shows you want to
do your best
so what is the best way to revise
hmm I might need some backup here
oh
this is Ruby Granger who says study tips
and advice on her YouTube channel and
trust me she knows what she's talking
about hi Ruby Hi dryer so what are the
best ways to revise
well the best thing you can do is active
recall so putting the things that you
are learning into practice doing flash
cards or practice questions that's
what's going to really prepare you to do
well in your exam
the other thing is just planning ahead
and scheduling your revision ahead of
time so you don't get too stressed you
don't get too overwhelmed instead of
doing three things a day practice on
doing one thing really really well and
schedule your study sessions into 45
minute bursts because it will help to
keep you more focused
you feel really stressed while you're
revising what can you do well you can
always talk to people talk to teachers
friends parents find someone trusted
that you can ask and then they can offer
you the support that you need the other
thing is just making sure that you're
doing things other than just revising so
make sure you're seeing friends taking
time to rest doing your hobbies this
will just help you to keep your exams in
perspective
so looking after yourself taking regular
breaks staying connected to friends and
family
seems pretty easy enough
what what's the anxiety about exams
still takes over well don't forget your
teachers are there to help they want you
to do well and have loads of tips they
can share
ask them what you should be covering and
get hold of fast papers
staying calm and positive all the time
is a big ask but don't feel like you
have to do this all on your own
okay so the big day is here what do we
do to keep our cool Ruby how do we
tackle the big run-up you want to make
sure you're getting plenty of sleep get
a good night's sleep the night before
because that will mean your brains more
focused when you come to sitting the
exam and also have a good breakfast have
something which is going to give your
brain the energy that it needs something
like porridge and fruit is a really good
option when you get to the example
big thing which lots of people slip up
on is getting too stressed letting
yourself get too stressed try not to
think about the exam agree with your
friends ahead of time you're not going
to talk about it what you could do is
bring a book and read a few pages of
that beforehand which should just help
to calm you down get your relaxed ready
to go in and set the exam
so we get inside the clock starts do you
have any advice so the first thing you
want to do is look through the exam
paper flick through and see where the
highest Mark questions are because
sometimes these will be at the back and
you want to make sure you leave time for
them but also you can be thinking about
your answers while you're doing the rest
of the paper so the other thing is if
you come across a question that you
don't know the answer to that
particularly challenging Don't Panic
Circle it move on you can come back to
it later you've got the whole rest of
the exam to show The Examiner what you
can do and how much you know what if I
don't get the grades I was hoping for
well because of the school exam system
we've all become fixated on grades but
grades aren't the endpoint and grades
also don't determine how intelligent
somebody is or how successful they're
going to be some of the most successful
people didn't do well in schools Like
Richard Branson Ed Sheeran Bill Gates so
just because you don't get the grades in
these exams doesn't mean you're not
going to be successful
Ruby that's all been really great advice
oh no worries dryer I'm glad I could
help
so exams are coming but with great
revision tips and knowing how to tackle
the day I'm not shutting up too much if
you try your best that's all you can do
ah I think I feel a lot calm already
how about this is there with a dog has
won the Guinness World Record for the
world's longest song on a dog she's a
mix between a Labrador and a German
shepherd and herd song measures are
whopping 12.7 centimeters from the tip
of her snout to the tip of a tongue
which means she's got the world record
licked
well that's nearly it for this week but
don't forget you can catch up on all our
episodes of FYI on our webpage at
first.use forward slash FYI but before
you go we can leave you with some
stunning images to Mark Wild Ocean day
see you next time bye
foreign
[Music]